I want to introduce your first alright
so um ladies and gentlemen shut the [ __ ]
up ladies and gentlemen you know I
started comedy in the in the late in the
late 90s and when I came to LA you know
I ran I would run into this guy you know
really nice guy but he was so funny he's
so funny
even as a young stand-up he was so good
and I don't know what why but we've
always gotten long we've always whenever
I see this guy we grab each other's
[ __ ] right
do we not yeah yeah yeah we'll rub it to
the ha clicks yeah it usually happens at
the improv right yeah but I mean back in
the day though it was like everywhere
would just be rant the random rooms yeah
all that [ __ ] I've always loved you
Bobby it's so funny when we say that we
started in the 90s like yeah it's so
[ __ ] weird it's [ __ ] crazy but um
and I'm gonna say this another
compliment of free about like when when
Harold and Kumar came out you were the
only comic to call me to tell me that I
did a good job
do you remember that probably not yeah I
do it's like [ __ ] yeah I mean that's I
remember that distinctly going oh what a
nice guy no one else ever called me
about you know I mean yeah and when
comics do that it's like it's such a
[ __ ] rare thing so let's give Nick
Swardson a round of applause everybody
[Applause]
kalila Bobby's girlfriend my girlfriend
kalila I kalila are you did you win the
most patient girlfriend in the world
Awards I'm difficult to live with I know
it's very different no you're not you're
sweet oh thank you buddy
so I just remember the [ __ ] all days
god what a tornado that used to be I
know
so don't what the greatest we survived
it all Hey
I always talk about that I've barely
barely survived but ah yeah there it's
funny when you look back and then people
go oh Jesus
and then I'm like it's I'm 43 now and
I'm like oh my god how the [ __ ] did I
make it to this far yeah I never thought
I would I was like there's no way I'm
gonna I would stalk when I saw 30 I was
like alright yeah because I mean you you
know you you're a wild guy you like to
have fun at nights no yeah I mean I
would go through just you know [ __ ]
where it was just a glass like you don't
realize as a comic I didn't go to
college I sort of stand it what like
right out of high school I was 19 so I
didn't have any school so I grew up in
clubs that's what I did I yeah so that
was my you know my teachers were [ __ ]
old Road comics yeah all these dudes are
a [ __ ] loose cannons so you know I
would go through phases of you know I
would focus and work and then when I was
and I was just like game [ __ ] on yeah
when I look back I don't look back at
like God man I remember when I was sober
for six months so fun I remember him
like god I remember I piss myself cago I
remember [ __ ] every story about the
crazy times I always like miss it makes
me going oh I mean I remember I don't
know if you'd ever do this I would do a
gig and I would just stay so I with you
I did one show one time in Miami one
[ __ ] show yeah I stayed for a month a
[ __ ] one yeah and that would happen
all the time yeah my Asia be like hey
what summit where are you it's like
you're not still in South Beach are you
Mikey I would have my openers who are
always my friends I'm like let's just
stay so one time in South Beach we
[ __ ] just kept staying and weeks
would go by and my opener Patrick Keynes
really funny loved him and he was like
are we like are we leaving and I'm like
I don't know who cares and he goes well
I I mean I have a life
yeah and I'm like I know but like what
do we just do this needs like what
yeah I'm not man running off an Amex car
being like so you know but it was so fun
yeah you look good though buddy what do
you been doing different we're
exercising yeah I've actually been
lifting things that I wouldn't normally
lift and putting them over my head
multiple times are you really I go to
the gym and [ __ ]